it is now the most notorious address in
Pakistan maybe the world and everyone
wants to see it the house where Osama
bin Laden is meant to have lived and
died is now the star attraction in
Abbottabad the children are picking up
fragments of the American helicopter
which was downed in the raid mementos
from an event already being furiously
disputed you will take the people you
will sure to the nation that's it that's
the thing what I have done but stay the
free yeah everybody wants to see if you
asking have even the super-psycho Pataki
Osama no no no no what I said to them
you got more there was Osama they said
no we don't believe that that's what i
said no for given here ninety percent
people said we don't believe that this
town was known only for its tranquility
before and its large military presence
along the Main Street hardly a building
goes by which is not connected in some
way to the Pakistani army
it's also the home to the country's
elite military academy the residents are
all still doing double-takes at the idea
that the man identified as the west
public enemy number one could have been
quiet to thinking out his days here
apparently without anyone in authority
knowing mayhem Ahmed woke to some of the
explosions and helicopter movies I
didn't know what is going on and with
this I I wasn't in my senses what
happened niram first man i love the
Obama no sorry Osama is my neighbor
surprised yessiree Namath the Shah
Mara's family live closest to the
compound and one of the sons worked as a
handyman their governmental no one was
allowed to go inside into the
residential area we used to just know
how to do the boundary walking they
would give us this of what you get them
from the market and we would just drop
it off the house is in a well-to-do area
but strangely it had no internet or
mobile phone connection or security no
doubt I mean look at the height of these
walls going to be at least 12 foot and
no other house around here has walls
that high but of course it was housing
the world's number one terrorist man
that everyone in the world was
apparently meant to be hunting even
Pakistan now you can't get further than
these gates now and has turned into
quite a tourist attraction with the
world's media and all the local
residents all desperate to see and be
close to this residence the Pakistani
authorities were now trying to a vessel
back control of this must be embarrassed
at the very least that the raid was
carried out apparently without informing
them the Americans have long been
suspicious that elements within the ISI
the
agency were sheltering this armor and
other leaders of you held by many
pakistani journalist there is a general
perception that if she was here next to
the Pakistan military academy it must
have been in the notice of those story
agencies but so far no agency or no no
other institution has claimed this
responsibility perhaps in an effort to
show how little they know about the
house officials began measuring the
exterior walls but few will be satisfied
until some physical evidence is produced
of usamos death and even then they'll
still be skeptics